let me welcome everybody to another
ideas that matter conversation I have
here a person I'm delighted to call a
friend and colleague uh Helen de Cruz
who is uh she got a lot of different
hats that she wears so I'll just mention
a few of them and then Helen if you want
to mention any others you certainly can
she is the Danforth chair in Humanities
at St Louis University she does a lot of
work work in both traditional academic
philosophy but also public philosophy
and we could say the things in between
and today we're going to be talking
specifically about academic publishing
which I think a lot of people have
really vague ideas about including
fellow academics and a lot of people
don't really understand that well so
we're going to delve into that and the
reason we're doing this is in part
because Helen is also an editor she has
edited uh a number of uh journals is on
editorial boards has published a lot
herself so she's gotten to see it from
different sides and I'm going to sort of
tap her brain uh both for information
and speculations about where we are when
it comes to academic publishing and so
actually let me start off if there isn't
anything else that you want to add um
I've got a question for you to kick off
with yeah so you're an author and you've
been on the side of the person having to
jump through the Myriad different Hoops
that come with academic publishing I'd
be interested I know what my experiences
are like which are rather mixed I'd be
interested to hear what yours are like
and we we often don't see this all we
see is oh you've got a book out oh
you've got this article that's come out
we don't usually hear hear about all of
the trials and tribulations that are
involved in getting something once
you've actually written it through the
editorial process the review process so
is there anything that comes straight to
mind for you I think if I had to say one
thing it's really luck it's unfortunate
because early in your career those
months that are ticking away when you're
waiting to hear about a manuscript can
be so
important but you don't have it under
control so a lot of it is bumping on the
right referees so the my first book my
first monograph is a co-authored
monograph and we sent it to O uh I think
it's okay to say it is not right so we
send it to and it took like 18 months I
kid you not 18 months for them to come
back with a rejection and there was one
positive referee and then there was very
very negative referee who had clearly
not read the book thought it was a cool
edited book rather than a cool authored
book and I thought well either the
chapters are not really hanging together
or this person has just not really read
it uh so that was really terrible
because yeah you would think yeah oh you
P book that's good on the CV but it just
so then we sent it to MIT press and
there it went really wonderful so the
editor there Phil Laughlin uh found the
right referees and he sort of went after
them to like get three reports so he got
three report thought uh it went really
quick really smooth we got a very strict
deadline to revise and I think it came
out really well and I think the referees
definitely helped the book and it's one
of I think it's my most cited work I
think that book uh it's basically it's
an exploration of the cognitive science
behind natural theological arguments
like why do people find arguments and
natural theology is so compelling why do
we keep on making these arguments even
though you can't prove that God exists
with them but keep on doing it so like
that's what the book is about uh and uh
that was a good experience but we also
had a very bad experience um with the
different Publishers so it's really just
luck uh and and obviously also editorial
like how how you know contentious are
the the editors how much do they want to
like sit behind the referees or they say
oh I can wait so it's really just that
uh it's luck um yeah that that's sort of
the main thing that comes to mind uh
with early publishing experience you
know we should uh we should spend a
little bit of time just in case people
aren't completely clear about how
academic editorial processes work and
you know we're not necessarily going to
speak for every single field I mean
we're we're both in the humanities um
you stray over into the Sciences to some
some degree as well um but you know
there is this notion of blind review of
that being sort of they call it a gold
standard this is why we can rely on
academic Publications so do you think
you could like for you know in a
thumbnail way for ordinary people talk
about how this process is supposed to
work and then we'll get into how things
actually do work okay so I'll just do it
for journals for journals what happens
is the editor gets the paper on the desk
it could be that the editor knows who
the author is in but then the the paper
is still anonymized so what happens that
suppose the editor knows who the author
is then the editor is going to uh write
to some referees uh which are people who
don't know who the author is and those
people are going to write a report about
this paper is great this paper is awful
this paper is okay but you know and
actually most papers that get published
they get a decision of this paper is
okay but so revise and resubmit or
revise with major or minor revisions and
that process can take a while uh mainly
because in my experience as editor um it
takes a while to get somebody to say Yes
um so so that's how the mons are taking
away typically the the referees get two
or three months uh or so to write up a
report now it's more like one month uh
and then the editor this is very
important it's not the reviewers who
make the decision it's the editor but
what will happen is that if one of the
reviewers didn't like it even if the
report is not that that that compelling
but if the referee did not like it the
editor is typically going to go with
reject uh that's just because so much is
being sent to to journals um if both
referees like it then it's really up to
the editor to read the reports really
carefully like you always read the
reports very carefully and make a
decision uh either to say no like
there's too many issues that's usually
the thing too many issues with this
paper it's going to be too difficult to
revise no or you say yes and then you
invite a resubmission the author
resubmits the reviewers get a second
look and then yes or no and then it get
published that's sort of like the
standard trajectory I'd say most Journal
articles that is that is the ideal thing
that we we hope and that way you have
Anonymous sper review because it's
people in your field your peers who have
evaluated your paper and who have U made
a judgment about it and then given that
to the editor who has made a decision
based on that so that's how the process
works in theory and you know because of
the way it's set up that provides a a
reliability you know if it's published
in this journal we can say aha it's gone
through blind review some as you pointed
out peer reviewers have said this is
this is acceptable this is
uh we may not agree with everything but
it's it's worth publication and an
editor has had weighed in on it um but
oftentimes there's glitches there's
problems that come up with it and you
mentioned the matter of luck who you get
as a Reviewer is particularly
significant right if perhaps they
haven't read the literature that you're
bringing up or they've read other
literature and they're obsessed with you
talking about that right uh and
sometimes you you know having worked on
um the other the other side myself of
being an editor and being a reviewer and
being on editorial boards I've I've seen
things I don't do this myself but I've
seen editors say find a reason to say no
to this paper and then hand it off to
people uh even without telling them who
it is you know ah or or the
opposite yeah that is very bad practice
I I think it's a big no it's a red flag
don't do it okay if you think as an
editor this paper is bad for whatever
reason for example I think one reason I
know this is not popular but say this
paper is morally objectional for example
a paper that says gay people should not
adopt uh children because you know gay
people are bad or whatever something
like that I think you have or you know
racial disparities in IQ I think that is
a reason
as an editor you decide what is
important and what not and I think you
know the bar for such a paper for me
would have to be very high uh and it is
usually not met upon desk reviewing so
yeah you are totally fine as an attitud
to say this is going no further even
just like there's so many mundane
reasons like this paper is just silly
this paper doesn't do anything like
those are also reasons you reject then
you just send a desk rejected into like
you don't Outsource send it to the
reviewer to you don't Outsource that
decision to reviewers you have to take
responsibility so when the moment you
send to reviewers the one is you just
say okay what do you think at this point
the reviewers know for rest philosophica
at least that it has already survived
some screening because we reject about
50% of what we get in uh the one reason
that I see find the reason to accept
this like I think that's bad too but
sometimes we have invited papers and
they're marked as such like this is an
invited paper of somebody who gave a
lecture with us you know so usually we
say something like constructive feedback
is is appreciated obviously the paper's
terrible tell us right but yet but the
paper is not marked as a normal peer
reviewed blind paper it's an invited
paper so I think it's fine then well and
it would be said so in in the journal as
well right in the issue yeah so I think
that just what you just described is bad
editorial practice I would say don't
don't people should not do this yeah now
this raises an interesting and bigger
problem because of the nature of peer
review there's an epistemological
problem that comes up for any of us who
want to speculate or generalize about it
we don't really know what other people
are doing except by talking with each
other right so you can never I mean if
you if you know people who are on the
editorial board and you understand the
kind of people that they are you can be
reasonably confident that things are
going the way they're supposed to but if
you don't know the people it's it's
difficult to say that all the requisite
processes are being carried out in the
way that they're supposed to and you
know I I think that for for right now it
seems like there is still a lot of trust
in AC ademic journals and articles um as
a a medium but you know all it would
take is enough critical mass of of you
know people saying oh yes we did this
wrong thing for that that confidence to
erode pretty quickly I think
uhuh I think sometimes you do see that
it goes wrong like uh there are moments
where for example hcia so a few years
years ago there was a big um a big
fuffle with Rebecca tuille writing this
paper about transracialism and people
being transgender and it's it generated
a whole Holo and the the it I remember
that yeah of hpaa resigned and then you
had to sa with philosophical psychology
a couple of years later and then you had
the Journal of political philosophy
where the editor and the publisher
apparently went and and fought so there
like drama and I think with drama uh
what is important uh is that the
editorial board uh steps in and makes a
recent decision so the editorial board
one of the things why do you put names
of people who are trustworthy who have
some reputation in the field you do that
because in situations like that the
editorial board has to step in and and
do something right so I think it's
important and and yes maybe maybe I I am
actually on on the team of people people
who say we do have a a crisis and we
should do something different but at the
same time I haven't quite figured out a
good alternative I think that's the
problem with lots of these yeah new new
ways to to do it that's a and that's a
very interesting broader problem too
going Beyond academic publishing there
are so many things where we can say aha
this is clearly not working the way it's
supposed to but what is the alternative
you know and in the case of academic
publishing I mean in in some
respects it's there's a strangle hold on
it by several big companies that have
managed to who have been allowed to
consolidate all these journals under
their their umbrellas and you
know essentially hire the Articles out
into databases which they they collect
the money for on the other hand because
of the existence of the internet if
somebody wants to create a new Journal
there's nothing stopping them other than
perhaps you know the the issue of
prestige and who's going to buy into
this but if you get enough you know
recognizable people on the board you
know uh working for it publishing in it
then you can you can establish something
quite easily I think so we should talk
about both sides of this um I think a
lot of people again out there don't
don't really know about the econom
comics of publishing that there are that
you know some of them to begin with
think that academics make money on their
Journal Publications now you can on
books not usually a lot you know I I get
checks every so often for my one book
that I I've published but I have to
reach a $100 threshold before they pay
anything out and so that means they
don't pay out every
year um but with academic publishing it
works almost in in Reverse where
um you are usually you're not having to
pay to play although with some Open
Access journals you actually do have to
pay as somebody sending in a a article
to get it reviewed and and uh published
um but you're not getting you're not
getting paid for the vast amount of work
that you've put into the average article
which may take you months and months to
write you know research and then
responding to the reviewer's comments
revising it um so who who actually does
make the money with this sort of thing I
mean there is a lot of money being made
right um I can speak to that yeah yeah
so um Ras philosophica um I'm the editor
of it now and it's our in-house Journal
it has existed since
1925 so we're coming up to our 100th wow
so it's an old an old joural in in
American terms and it has gone through a
lot of incarnations it used to be like
something for Catholic philosophy and
then it became it was the modern
schoolman you know about like and now
it's a general Jour so because we are
not open access and it's not my decision
to change that like it's it's a it's
part of our institutional context so it
can't change it even if I wanted to uh
we have an agreement with the philosophy
Documentation Center and they publish it
for us they publish print issues which
are like I think about
$75 a year year subscription so that's
not terribly expensive and we also have
online subscriptions institutional
subscriptions anyway all those
subscriptions generate revenue for us
that we split with the publisher and
about half of so I think I don't know
exactly what our deal is again with them
but I do know that we can organize every
two years a nice conference the rest
philosop conference and we do use the
money of the journal for that so and the
conference also gives a special issue
and it's usually on a really fun cut
Cutting Edge topic so it gives an
invited special issue and we can get
like usually something like five or so
invited speakers and we can host them
and we can have a dinner so that's nice
so that I can tell you where the money
goes the the money for us goes to us
being able to organize a really fun
conference every two years which is is a
great benefits to um whereas if we went
Open Access honestly uh that Revenue
would would would seize and uh we you
know we wouldn't be able to organize
this nice conference anymore and it's
actually similar for lots of other
journals too so I was once on a really
nice in a really nice restaurant a
michelan star drest the first and the
last time and I was there with Dan
sperber like he's one of my heroes uh
and he uh was I think co-editor or at
the very least of the editorial board of
mind and language and likewise they
organize events and they go eat with
speakers with the money that they make
so that's what I think academics do with
it like editors Etc some some journals
like Santa pay their editors but it's a
huge job to be editor and chief of cesa
cesa gets a very high publication load
that is such a huge job you do have to
pay the editor um so I think long story
short lots of money just goes to these
big Cong cerates to Wy to Springer Etc
some money goes to editors I don't get
paid for instance for this but if it's a
big Journal then yes you usually do get
paid and money goes to institutions to
host people to organize events Etc we
should point out that probably at least
in philosophy the majority of editors
are not getting paid it's it's work that
is being done mostly by professors and
it counts towards service for or um you
know accounting for advancement tenure
those those sorts of matters yeah that's
right yeah yeah now uh what about the
the other side of that with you know you
could effectively start up new journals
if you want to um I mean there there do
seem to be some obstacles to that it it
it's a lot of work right and you have to
figure out how you're going to if you
going to have subscriptions how you're
going to handle that and how you're
going to get the word out and how you're
going to get people to send articles in
but it's not insurmountable and we've
seen you know a number of journals say
in the last 30 years uh created uh I'll
just give you one example the that I've
published in quite a bit from time to
time and reviewed for and that's the St
Ansel Journal associated with The
Institute for St anel studies and um
they're with philosophy Documentation
Center as well although they weren't
originally and you know they you you get
your your Publications uh out there
through it if they're on ansom or other
related topics and it was just a bunch
of people professors at St anel's
College who were like well we should
start a journal obviously they had some
experience with these things but it it
was something that was uh feasible to do
um I actually when I was much younger
tried to start a journal uh with my at
that time uh fiance and a few other
people and had no idea what I was doing
and we managed to get two issues out and
it went belly up you know um so you know
you do have to have an A a knowledge
base let's say or or a base of expertise
um I mean what do you think the
prospects are let's say you know you and
I and a few other people wanted to
create a journal tomorrow or start on
creating a journal tomorrow obviously
it's not going to happen tomorrow um how
difficult do you think it would be it's
not insurmountable as you see but it is
it is tough it is tough I've been
thinking a few times about journals uh
but uh I've had a few ideas but then I
think like I don't want to end my life
as I know it so I'm not do it like also
I feel that once you do it you have to
be in it for the long haul and it also
became very apparent to me when I first
had this conversations it was the idea
of an Journal of experimental philosophy
okay that was when I was at Oxford
Brooks my previous institution which is
very SC cash strapped like they're now
closing departments and stuff like that
not the philosophy Department yet
fortunately um but they they were very
cash strapped and when I saw like what
are the options of the library or the
department or whatever putting uh
something towards that then the answer
was just no not even like you know some
some reduction in my other service and
things like that so so it was very clear
now what was not the problem was getting
people for the editorial board so people
like it works very reputationally and I
felt like I I had enough sort of capital
Social Capital to get people on board to
be part of the editorial board it's not
that big of a job actually right the
only thing is like you have to be
responsible like your name could be
Associated too in a bad way if the
journal goes really bad so there has to
be this trusting relationship but you
don't have to do much else except like
if something goes really horribly wrong
uh so that was not the problem but then
there was the issue of like Open Access
Open Access is expensive uh you could
arrange it with PDC and it costs tens of
thousands of dollars like even if you
want like Ergo or fill in print with
something different it's still going to
be expensive and Ergo I've been part of
their editorial team now for a while
they uh they just keep on trying to find
ways to like make this journal not a
complete Money Pit like for example
asking people to pay something when they
submit submission fees so that's one way
that they do it so there's all this
costructure that makes it really
difficult now you could just say okay
I'm just going to go with Springer or
something like that and then it's
easier it's easier but I really don't
like uh that a few places like elae and
spring I can like so it wouldn't be my
preferred mobile they dominate the
market essentially they dominate the
market they get most of the money out of
it uh they they profit so much uh so so
because of that because I didn't want to
go with something like Springer or ele
or any of these others um it becomes
more difficult it's just not easy I
think the cost structure is the most
difficult thing the other thing is
indeed you have to get the word out so
some journals do actually flounder
because they don't get enough quality
submissions so then you have to jump
through lots of other Hoops um for
example I was part of the editorial team
of the Journal of analytic Theology and
at some point we were thinking how about
getting indexed in scopus arts and
humanities index but honestly the amount
of paperwork that you have to fill out
for these sorts of things is uh
substantial interesting see yeah does
and does that require a lot of
cooperation from the authors as well
getting them to provide abstracts if
they haven't provided them already or
you know I think no because you can ask
the auth whatever right I mean within
the bounds of reason but you just say
like provide an abstract they'll do it
give keywords so that's not an issue the
issue is more like that you have to
document if you want to get indexed into
one of these fancy repositories you have
to provide evidence that you have a good
review process that you're accountable
right that you have for example a thing
in place I remember this for one of them
I forgot which which of them maybe
scopus a process in place to handle data
I thought well we're the Journal of
analytic theology like we don't like how
are data stored like we don't have data
like our data are
theological like there's no like we're
not an experimental no the thing is that
that there has to be this sort of clause
and you know so so there there's a lot
of hoop jumping for this sort of thing
that's interesting let me uh shift the
topic slightly to
another perhaps looming crisis and I'd
really like to get your your take on
this
issue so it's been noticed and talked
about lately that there are quite a few
people who are turning down the
opportunity to review and this is making
the review time quite a bit longer for
journals which slows down the
publication process and I'm I myself
have taken a position on this I'm an
adjunct and I've been a reviewer
probably for 25 years and recently
I started with a few exceptions if I
have a you know a close friend who asks
me for a favor like you know I'll always
review for the St anom Journal because I
like those those people but I've had
quite a few
um editors who did two things they they
would first put me into their electronic
system and and tell me okay uh we expect
you to review this this paper uh you're
already in the system just click the
things that you need to click and then
um you know they're asking me also if I
would consider reviewing a paper and my
response to them in the last several
years has been well I don't do
uncompensated work anymore because I'm
an adjunct and um I've already done sort
of my my work for this over years if
you're willing to compensate me for my
work I'd be happy to to do that and then
of course they email back and they say
well none of us are compensated and I
say well that sounds like a business a
structuring problem to me you know uh
maybe you should think about um figuring
out how you're going to you know award
stiens or something like that otherwise
uh take me out of your your system now
I'm I'm kind of at an extreme on that I
think um but I think there's a lot of
other academics that are a bit more
traditionally located let's say who are
burnt out and um don't feel that they
need to step up and volunteer and be a
reviewer because it is uncom compensated
work and you know it's viewed as service
but I don't think that committees look
at that quite the same way even though
it is a lot of work that service the way
they do at say organizing conferences or
being an editor or something along those
lines and so I'm I'm very sympathetic to
the idea that we do have a a crisis here
and and um it is slowing things down
significantly to the point where I'm
even sure if I want to send papers out
because it could be you know years
before they get review rather than
months as as it should be precisely
because of people like me but others
others as well who are opting out of the
process and I so I'm you know you're I
haven't been doing editorial work in the
way that you have for a number of years
you're right there in the middle of it
first of all is is this like a live
issue or are people kind of overplaying
it in social media and then second where
do you find your your
sensibilities lying on on this
one yeah so I feel so first and for all
I think there genuinely is a crisis I
saw a serious decline in people wanting
to review so this is like I've been an
editor in variz capacities I think since
2017 or something like okay uh for
different journals so Journal of
analytic theology it was my job to find
referees I was executive editor find
referees and then the ultimate decision
was then the the the senior editors so I
look for for papers uh for people to to
send to and then 2020 happened and then
two things happened one is enormous
enormous amounts of papers mainly by
Christian male grad students uh it
wasn't triple blank so I knew it was
mainly Christian male grad students they
sent like huge amounts like it's a
journal of analytic theology right
analytic philosophy of religion and and
theology uh and yeah they sent huge
volumes of mostly not very rigorous uh
work basically uh so so some of it could
be just desk rejected but some of it you
know did look plausible so we then had
to find reviewers but yeah it was 2020
and so people were saying no and you
know that's understandable but I kind of
feel like the burnout continued like
it's almost like okay it's all over now
we should all all be okay again but
actually people are just very burnt out
like this is not just the corona crisis
but a variety of other things that make
us increasingly burnt out the fact that
the you you say you know as you point
out you're an adjunct and the fact that
we have adunc ification means that we
have fewer colleagues who can do this
indeed purely as service in an
Institutional context like I think yes
it doesn't mean much on your CV uh to to
review but it doesn't have to what
you're actually doing is you're
benefiting from a system and you're
paying into the system it's a bit like
you know picking up dirt or you know
like with these tweezers when you go out
in the park like as a community effort
right you're like these people with the
tweezers in the park you know you do
this sort of thing as a community
and I think refereeing is like that I
think it is truly selfless but at the
same time it benefits you in directly
because you are part of the
institutional context in which reviewing
works but that also means like if you're
an Adent then basically you don't get a
lot of the benefits that are part of the
institution so I totally understand I
try to avoid asking agent for that
reason CU I think like you know they are
not we have a lot of colleagues who are
not fully there like this is the thing
how actually agenc ification also hurts
tenure people because we have fewer
people who can do that sort of thing or
who ought that sort of thing right so
yeah that that's where I I wonder with
with some adjuncts um I mean being an
adjunct is quite difficult I I think
that if you're trying to do it full-time
it's a it's a terrible way to live you
know because you get paid very little
you have very little security fulltime
can come around and poach your classes
if they if they think they're attractive
or they want to earn a little extra
money themselves which I've seen happen
quite a bit um so there's there's a
sense I think of
disengagement and um disillusionment
with the the whatever you want to call
it the community right um and as you
pointed out there are more and more
adjuncts it's been going up you know I
could look at Marquette University just
down the road here they have
hired um full-time positions very much
in in philosophy as people leave for
quite a while they just hire visiting
assistant professors who are teaching
four classes per semester you know have
have you know limited term contracts or
they just hire a bunch of adjuncts or of
course graduate students and that's
really great that they they get that
experience to teach um and I think
that's that's pretty representative of
where a lot of American schools are I
don't know it is in in other places but
um if you are an adjunct you know
especially a younger career adjunct
somebody who got their PHD say in the
last six years or so and went out on the
job market maybe had some interviews
didn't get hired anywhere has been just
sort of like trying to keep things going
um I I don't know that that many of them
will be thinking along the lines of well
I really want to be part of this
professional class
um I'm going to benefit from it because
I'm going to write my articles because
they don't have time to write a lot of
Articles if they're if they're teaching
all the time um therefore I should do
this this uh service work if you if
you've lost those people I mean for
people like me you know mid-career
academics kind of doesn't matter what I
do you know because another 20 years and
I'll be gone um but with these younger
people in their 20s and 30s if we lose
them as part of the philosophical
Community being willing to put in you
know work um seeing that there's
something as a return for them some sort
of
reciprocity I think that we're in a lot
of trouble then in the years
ahead yeah I've been thinking about that
like as I was making my committee for
the AP Central 2025 which is a huge huge
uh Service public yeah yeah and and like
normally we only ask 10 years people but
I thought like could I deviate from it
and they said yeah sure because I
thought like what is the future of our
profession right that's why I asked two
agent so there's you and there is one
other
agent I thought it's important right you
are part of the philosophical Community
like this conference should be also for
agent so I think this is maybe the first
time that agents are in this committee
uh but I'm hoping that you will give me
a different viewpoint on like like how
can we envisage you know doing the
things that we do the the institutional
things
publishing uh doing Outreach to the
public teaching yeah uh you know and and
that sort of other thing um so I think
yeah it's it's it's difficult to think
like there are so many people who had to
give up basically so so one person that
I'm thinking about in particular he said
I really identify as a philosopher and
yeah obviously he has a philosophy PhD
and he's been working on all sorts of
visiting positions for years now but he
had to give that up like he wanted
security he wanted to be able to settle
down somewhere with his family uh and he
kind of thought like yeah what what am I
now how can I still be part of this so
we're losing so many people who really
are like who have really interesting
ideas and you know through through
stupid dumb luck like how often is it
not luck like you have an interview and
you get hired or not hired the First
Choice turns down the University or does
not and that could make the difference
between you being in the profession or
not in the profession down the line like
it's just surreal to think about that
yeah I had a colleague when I was at
fville State University who was hired at
the same time that I was in 2008 and um
she had been out teaching for nine years
she got her PhD a little bit before I
had and she lived in seven different
places in those nine years because she
kept on getting not postdocs but you
know temporary one or two year teaching
positions and by the time that she got
to this tene track position at fville
State University she was so burnt out
that she she did she made some efforts
to try to publish some things from her
dissertation on um I was on platonic
dialogues and I I I think it was on the
one of the
alabes and she just didn't have the
presence of mind the heart to try to to
see this stuff through while teaching a
44 teaching load and and on being
expected to do some committee stuff as
well and she she was still there when I
left and she didn't end up getting
tenure because she um she couldn't find
her her way to jumping through those
publishing
Hoops um and I I don't know where she is
now I think she found a full-time job
somewhere down the line but for a while
she was totally off the the map she you
couldn't find her anywhere on the
internet and I think there's lots and
lots of people in Sim similar situations
to that where um the process grinds them
down and they're unable to do the things
that people looking in from the outside
or people in in the tenure track are
like well why didn't you just do this
you know um and and we don't we don't
take them into account all that often in
part because we tell these individual
stories rather than talking about things
more systematically but then again
there's this epistemological problem we
don't actually know exactly how many
people are even uh on you know at
working as adjuncts for um limited time
uh no no actual security
positions um I don't I don't see figures
for that readily available out there
it's also just purely visual go to my uh
department for instance which is just
like I would say an average philosophy
department and you will not see the
agent listed on our page anywhere we
have a page of faculty and we have a
page of hero are grad students but like
the the the sort of not so not so bright
reality is there's also agents who come
and teach H and they just not we don't
have that many but I'm thinking why not
why not give them like our agents you
know
but we don't right and this is common
like some people do L them but but but
many people
don't yeah I think it might be difficult
too because you never know if they're
going to be there one semester or
another right so yeah I think that's
that's part of it but if somebody's been
there several years teaching on and off
like why not just list them that's true
yeah
yeah so coming back to um the publishing
issue um we do have a crisis going on
with several different
dimensions and we are people who are
kind of thinking about the future um I
mean academic articles are still held up
as a an app you know a very important
standard they get used in public
discourse they
are the bulk of what I think people look
at in tenure and promotion within tenure
track lines and and things like that but
um you know you've pointed this out in
in many places there are many different
genres in which philosophy can be done
and we ended up settling on something
from like a you know 2,000 to maybe
8,000 word essay uh as like the the
standard now there are some journals
where you can publish longer pieces as
well but it seems kind of arbitrary that
we single this length of of writing out
as like the the key thing that we we
need to be focusing on
um what else should we be doing you know
what what else should we be counting do
you
think uh so I feel that um there are so
many different ways to do philosophy um
and I think we shouldn't just focus on
academic articles the reason we do is in
a sense it's easy a 10 your five
interesting easy like it's easy to
evaluate oh yeah look this person has
eight articles that that's about what we
should count like often there's
something like what you review 10 your
files and I've done many now uh I always
get a few invitations like would you
like to review some person's work for
the last six years and make an
evaluation about what did they should
get 10 year difficult um it's easy in a
sense because you get a 10e requirements
and they say well we want at least eight
10 whatever articles in peer review
International journals of good standing
so you can easily see that you say oh
this is a paper in like philosophical
psychology philosophical studies and
Ergo and you say oh these are all great
journals right so you already feel
confident so the journal is like this is
something so Neil Levy has a book on
peer rreview and that's sort of
the book this book's title that's just
come out uh it's a it's a Cambridge
element where he says actually what do
these journals do right you can just put
things on your repository you can
already put your pre-prints on fil
papers like what does a journal do well
a journal is a bit like a brand like it
just sort of gives you this thing like
oh if it's published in news it must be
good right if but but of course what if
the person never thought of sending
their Pap to news and just thought like
oh I'm going straight to say philosophia
because yeah I like philosophia then you
know already the reputation is a lot
less but it could still be a great
papers so you don't know that so that's
the ological opacity that you have there
so basically what that system advantages
is people who say yeah this is a great
paper I'm going to send it to the top
journals um but it does give you this
sort of Licensing so that's why we look
at journals because it's it's easily
quantifiable these Journal publication
names they give you a kind of stamp of
approval and then of course you read the
papers as well right for tenure file but
that sort of thing already helps you to
give context
other things like say public philosophy
writing it's a lot less clear so I think
we do need to count it but we shouldn't
require that everybody does public
philosophy I think it is something that
can go yeah you know yeah I think it's
good well there there are some people
who are doing public philosophy and
they're doing it very poorly and you're
you're almost like it's sort of like
listening to somebody who's I don't know
just learning a musical instrument or
they they they just don't have the
musical ear and you're a musician so
you're you're familiar with this there's
some people who you're like oh maybe
leave that to somebody else you know
that's true but it takes a while
sometimes like it takes a while to to
understand this register it's a
completely different register and many
people when they read your public
philosophy this is another thing and you
do it well and I think I do it
reasonably they don't understand what
it's doing like why didn't you put all
these 1,000 nuances in here well that's
because it's not are you getting that
mostly from academics or you getting
that also from let's just call them as
McIntyre does plain persons or ordinary
it does happen like that people say like
he didn't mention this and you didn't
mention that but you think yeah there's
a piece of 2,000 words max if it's for a
newspaper it's even less like how much
can you do like there's only so much you
can do yeah besides also this is sort of
an unrelated academic take but I think
Nuance is overrated like I honestly
think you just have to sometimes boldly
say this is what I hold without like
qualifying it like I feel that we are
being overtrained to qualify like as
academics as academics and we should do
it like put parentheses Etc like I think
you should just boldly say what you're
saying and then yeah you can look at
some obvious objections and such but um
I think it's helping me doing public
philosophy to also try to be a bit
bilder you know in my other writing so I
think in short uh we count many
different ways in which we can reach the
public our colleagues and so on um the
journal
article the journal article is a nice
form but it's just one of the forms one
of the many
forms yeah so I I I mean I like that
that idea not we shouldn't throw the
journal articles away and say oh this is
anti-philosophical or something like
that because clearly it's a great way to
do some kinds of
philosophy um what other what other
genres do you think have great potential
in the present I mean we can look back
and we can say well you know the
medieval disputation wonderful you know
look at Thomas aquinas's dialectical
method in this I don't know that that
many people are going to do that mode of
of thinking things through what do you
see in the present as some of the the
better ways to to do it one thing I've
been trying to revive with mixed success
I can now report on the success is in
July I started a new format for on
restful oopa and the format is called
restful shorts and it's basically the
idea of writing short papers of Max
3,000 words but they don't necessarily
have to be analytic style so the the
main Journal that does papers of this
length is the journal analysis and it's
just a wonderful Journal it's beautiful
but it's very analytic so if your papers
are not analytic philosop opy it's not
going to work but I thought like you
know how about like you have Michelle
the mon and other people like that and
they write these essays of two words and
like wouldn't it be delightful to have
small essays like that you know bold
essays that don't have space for all the
qualifications so you have to make your
case uh and anyway started that got an
enormous amount of submissions oh that's
really interesting really interesting so
there is definitely a mar Market but so
far we've only accepted one so the first
one is coming out it's a very
interesting piece it's a co-authored
piece by two people who work on and I
forgot their names now uh because yeah I
only see the name once I click on accept
yeah this is how it goes with rville um
it's about the arguments are metacogn
meta cognitive in in character that any
argument always is about thinking about
thinking uh which I think was very
interesting but but actually what I was
hoping for was like be wild people like
write write fun things like write essays
like I thought the essay is a great form
like we can do the essay again and
there's other outlets like the Raven
magazine Aon you know other places like
that right the philosophical essay is
getting a Revival um and well so now
that's that's that's an interesting
point there's like an entire blogosphere
out there online magazine sphere let's
call it where anything from 700 Words
which is really pretty tough to do much
in all the way up to maybe like 4500
words and that's there's maybe a sweet
spot with 3,000 words in that and I mean
these pieces are being read and widely
circulated and discussed so they're
having a a greater impact than many
academic
articles traditional uh academic
articles are right right yes I think so
I I'll give you one example there's a
piece it's not the piece that I just
recently published but an older piece
that I published in Eon and uh I sent it
to a journal like I had a long version
of this Pap okay I sent it to a journal
and obviously it got like two referee
reports uh and they were basically both
like this is a this is terrible this is
this is not good this doesn't make
relevant literature references this
doesn't talk about objections and blah
blah you know I laugh because I've heard
all these things so many times before so
what did I do I thought okay I I don't
know if I still want this as a journ
article so what I did was I basically
started trimming it trimming it trimming
it Del 3,000 words and then I wrote to
one of the editing the commissioning
editors in Eon and I asked you are you
interested in a piece on science and or
and they said yeah sure science and all
uh just do something uh so I sent this
piece and then we work together to to
like make it better and then it came out
so I got lots of people emailing me like
people who work in Wildlife Conservation
scientists Etc saying how great this
piece was how it resonated with them I
got the editor of um uh you know
Princeton University pressing like would
you like to write a whole book about
that and in fact interesting uh I got so
many positive comments so I thought
clearly this piece is not so terrible as
two referees because many people think
it's great I mean uh I wouldn't have
written my book if it weren't for that
piece and you know I even had an agent
reach out to me about writing a trade
book uh so like I don't know it was a
very strange experience it makes me
think about this we you know a lot of
people in philosophy and in the
humanities don't really know and engage
with the history of the the discipline
those of us who do we know about the you
know uh enlight Enlightenment era
Republic of letters this this sort of
circulation of journals and articles and
people talking in coffee shops all the
way up to you know like letter exchanges
and things like that and it strikes me
that the sort of response that you have
is sort it's not the same thing
obviously because we live in an internet
age as the Old Republic of letters it's
it's uh something different but it's
much more analogous to it than the
professional networks that we we tend to
think about and and work within and you
know maybe I I don't know what sort of
word we need or or epithet we need for
what it is that seems to be developing
in spaces for public philosophy but um
maybe that's where we should be putting
much more of our effort especially given
that at least here in the states there's
this uh you know great resistance to
Philosophy from many people desire to
cut it out of uh Academia uh in a lot of
ways
um I love the ideas that you bringing up
like the letters I think the letter the
philosophical letter is such a beautiful
genre and one of the sort of like pipe
dream ideas I have is to Once edit a
book just with philosophical letters and
a wide range newer ones or classical
ones Wang yangang Ming and Elizabeth of
Bohemia
you know all those great people and
speaking of which like I think one of
the reasons 17th century philosophy is
so awesome so I love 17th century
philosophy is precisely because it was
not that academically entrenched you had
like people who were just sitting at
home and doing something else like
Elizabeth of bohemia who could be like
fully engaged in a philosophical
profession uh because it was it was a
you know it it had a professional
character but at the same time you had
people from all sorts of walks of life
who could do it and the barriers for
entry were such that you know you could
had women for example uh before when it
was completely in a sort of schoolman uh
context they couldn't do it but now that
it became sort of
domestic like it it became much more
accessible and now we have again the
schoolman this well there some school
women as well but to be honest it's
exclusionary right the way it was before
so I'm I'm I'm sort of hoping that I
don't know what the future philosophy
holds like I know that we are under
assault of Administrators Etc but at the
same time I'm thinking like philosophy
has been going on for so long like they
can't they can't eradicate us it has to
go on in some form and maybe the public
philosophy sphere like YouTube substack
you know these Pro these platforms all
have their problems like they're being
basically held by a few like very small
groups of people with a l of power you
know do you remember I think it was last
year Brian van nordon had a number of
really great videos on Chinese
philosophy in his channel and something
happened and YouTube decided I think to
close his whole Channel and
unfortunately he didn't have them backed
up I mean I I actually like I I've got a
hard drive sitting right next to me all
the videos that I do they're on that
hard drive if a fire breaks out here I'm
grabbing that hard drive and taking off
um don't trust the cloud because I I
just don't trust these things like
exactly well these these platforms that
can that can change people are often
saying to me this is a bit of a side
note because I want to come back to the
Brian van nordon example they're always
like oh you know you do this work on
YouTube it's going to be a work for the
ages and it'll be out there forever
teaching people long after you're dead
and my response is always well let's
hope that YouTube is around 10 years
from now because who knows you know um
that's that's why we got to have these
things backed up elsewhere but with
Brian van nordon fortunately there was
enough pressure brought onto YouTube
that of course they they've got the
stuff right they never leaves their
servers and so they reinstated his
channel and he was like you know now I'm
gonna start backing my stuff up lesson
learned so yeah we're it's not great to
be dependent on these huge tech
companies
for the distribution the storage of the
work that we're
doing yeah this is a big problem so
there wasn't an a letter about substack
like I have to say it's working very
well for me so substack is this
newsletter program and basically you
allow people to subscribe for money or
for free and since I have a stable job
for me it's for free uh and then you can
get like my musings and ramblings and uh
that has grown quite quickly but then
there were people saying like you also
platform white supremacy IST uh you know
like why doing that yeah substack why is
substack doing that and like that's
going to be an issue uh always the thing
like for me it's like well if the
affordances are okay like obviously it's
not great what the platform but we have
to live in an imperfect world so I had
many beautiful threads on Twitter but
then Twitter sort of got ruined because
of the the the way that it works now
like the stuff that I see is not very
interesting anymore so a lot of that
work is simply lost and a lot of work
that I've done earlier on other
platforms is also going so a lot of it
feels very ephemerial right like I don't
know how what the future is of our
videos on YouTube like if you make
videos on Tik Tok what if the US
governments decide oh we don't want Tik
Tok uh then then it's gone right so so
you're very dependent like you know the
thing with rhetoric with with speaking I
was talking to this rhetoric Professor
we had coffee in in SLO and he said look
I ask my students like what do you do to
do public Outreach and they say oh you
have to begin with an interesting hook
and you have to write in a compelling he
said no the first thing you think about
is like who are you going to talk to how
are you going to reach these people and
that's the thing with like if we go back
to academic publishing you know that's
why we're still in that structure like
those there are these channels of
communication we know the channels of
communication we know a book with is
going to have cleared some you know
hurdles you know so so that's why we
have to rely on on pre-existing channels
like there there is no it's I'm not
saying there's no other way but it's
very difficult to do it in other
way yeah I mean you you almost need to
have uh what What's the the term
diversification you know um there's a
lot of people are like well you you
really need to figure out what your
Niche is and just stick to that Niche
boy if you do that
um that's pretty dangerous to do because
you could be eliminated you know
overnight by some policy decision made
by some middle manager somewhere you
know yeah I feel now because it's sort
of up in the air I don't know what the
future brings uh that you have to be
nimble and diverse you have to be
willing to willing to jump to to move
ship to jump ship uh and and hopefully
stay AF flat that's that's sort of how I
I see it now yeah so I want to be
respectful of your time but there is one
thing that you you mentioned very
briefly that I want to get uh you to
talk a little bit about more so the
American philosophical Association
really the the flagship Organization for
philosophers here in America among many
others um you are organizing something
very new which is an entirely online
version of the central
conference traditionally it's always
been face to face and you you've gotten
tasked with this immense project that
you've brought a lot of people in
including myself and um I you know I
think it's a great thing to do um it's
also something that I think you've made
a good case for as being
necessary
for the profession we need to think
about how to do online conferences
better than we have been doing and Co
gave us a boost for this sort of thing
right a lot of conferences did go online
a lot of them sucked so so you know I'm
I'm going to be very pous with this
you're trying to create a conference
that's not gonna suck that's actually
gonna be good um what's you want to say
a little bit about that I don't actually
have a specific question but this is an
opportunity for you to throw anything
out there that you'd like because I
think you know people watching listening
to this they could get quite excited
about that I hope so yeah I feel that
it's it's co did give us a boost uh and
I do still really like like you know I
my main reason for uh advocating first
for doing it online is just the climate
crisis uh and actually I'm very bad in
that respect because I feel like I went
to Singapore can you imagine in
September for a conference where they
invited me I couldn't say no but it's
bad right like my my karma my CO2 karma
is just terrible but I feel like a
profession if we have some online
conferences it'd be so good it it
eliminates a lot of problems for people
who don't have the money to travel who
don't who face all sorts of Visa
problems uh to travel um for people who
just don't want to do long-term travel
anymore for ethical reasons uh so for
that sort of reason it's good and it's
also just good to have a variety of
different ways for us to interact so I
did do some conferences that were really
really really terrible on during the co
times where even like they forgot to
like put on the camera at some point for
like it it was sort of hybrid and they
just forgot about the people who were
hybrid and I just didn't see the lecture
that I really wanted to see so it was
bad uh but at the same time I really
also saw some really interesting things
that otherwise I would not have been in
because yeah would I just go as a
participant to some Workshop in
Princeton on something that I'm not
really 100% working on but vaguely
interested probably know but I would
tune in online so it's really good uh
for us to do this um and yeah so the
thing is with live conferences they were
terrible in the beginning like
apparently I've heard people for getting
to order food and then people sitting
there at noon and like moderation that
goes all AR and talks that go horribly
over time so there's all sorts of things
that can happen with inperson
conferences like they're not perfect and
we have had many many decades to perfect
them now we can't really say after two
years oh you know online conferences
really suck we haven't given it an
honest shot so we need a bit of a
learning curve but we do lots of things
online that we enjoy we watch YouTube
online we you know like we we do social
media online so why wouldn't an online
conference work like I don't see primary
ficial reason why not uh I think for
various reasons of accessibility and
climate and so on we should give it a
good shot and if we can make something
that people get something out of and
that does not suck then I would say
mission accomplished and then like we
can continue to learn and and get better
at it over rather than striving for
Perfection trying to yeah yeah let's
just go for like good good enough
because the the online apas I think
people did the best they could during so
2020 2021 I think even 2022 there was
still an an online APA and I went to two
of those
they were okay but like there were lots
of problems but you know uh now we can
plan in advance so that that'll already
be
better well you've been very generous
with your your time and your expertise
and your your thoughtfulness here so I'd
like to thank you for coming on I always
enjoy conversations with
you anything that you'd like to plog or
alert people to that we haven't already
talked about
okay if I had to say something then it
is come to our Central APA and it's
going to happen in February 2025 and you
could just sit in your couch and see
World experts talk about things so yeah
that's what I want to plug it's a bit
early maybe but um look out for that for
the
2025 entirely virtual Central APA
division meeting all right well thank
you so much Helen de Cruz for coming on
thank you so much
my